hey what's up guys I'm Kay PhD here and
the HTC one looks to be pretty much the
best phone of 2013 right now and it's
got a pretty awesome feature set to back
that up it has a great spec sheet it has
an awesome build quality whole bunch of
awesome things about it but one feature
about it seems to be generating the most
buzz that the most people are talking
about and that is the camera so this is
the ultra pixel explain alright so the
traditional smartphone camera resolution
is measured in megapixels four megapixel
cameras then eight megapixel cameras
then 12 and 13 megapixel cameras became
the norm so as we see all the specs of
other phones like clock speed of the CPU
and amount of RAM and all sorts of other
things like battery size increase in
number we automatically assume that
bigger is better with all these specs
and the same thing happens to the
megapixel count so now we see 12 and 13
megapixel cameras and the average
customer just sort of assumes that a 12
megapixel is better than an 8 megapixel
when then that's not necessarily true
the average consumer making this
decision without actually knowing
anything else about the camera like the
lens or the image processor became known
as the megapixel race and that's still
kind of seen today but the megapixel
count is literally just a resolution
it's the resolution of the image that
this sensor takes so an 8 megapixel
camera sensor will take a 32 64 by 24 48
image which is significantly larger than
anything that our TVs or computer
monitors can natively show usually our
best computer monitors can only show up
to maybe 5 megapixels natively so you
will only be able to tell the difference
between an 8 megapixel and a 13
megapixel if you do some zooming or
cropping or printing it on a really
large size so HTC has decided to take a
risk and not get involved in the
megapixel race and instead develop their
own technology up til now smart phone
sensors and the cameras have stayed
about the same size but manufacturers
have been cramming more and more pixels
into those so we've seen it go from 4
megapixels to 8 like we said to 12 and
13 and even higher and as you cram that
many more pixels onto the same size
sensor the pixels get significantly
smaller and smaller which means you get
less and less light
pixal when you get less light in the
image or at least less light per pixel
you're going to see more noise grain and
worse low-light performance
that's where HTC has decided to switch
things up and crime far less pixels on
to the sensor they use a four megapixel
sensor which means that yes there are
far less pixels but those pixels are a
lot bigger which means you will get more
light and you'll get far less grain and
you will get better low-light
performance
so yes the HTC One is outfitted with a
four megapixel camera it takes four
megapixel photos very very small photos
comparatively speaking but these are
huge pixels which is where the ultra
pixel name comes from and since it's
only a four megapixel sensor HTC has
decided not to even talk about the
resolution count and completely change
it over with ultra pixels and sort of
mask that embarrassingly low megapixel
count so what's the difference between a
4 megapixel and a 4 ultra pixel camera
well nothing really we haven't seen
anything
HTC said that has confirmed that there
is any difference at all I mean they
like to talk a lot about their
technology but as far as we know maybe
smartphone sensors have gotten a tiny
bit bigger over the years as we get
bigger phones and they get more room in
the internals but really the individual
pixel size has remained pretty small so
now the HTC One while it does have the
lowest megapixel count of any smartphone
today it also does have by far the
largest pixels in any other sensor in
any other high-end smartphone so there's
a trade-off worth it how does it perform
to be honest paired with the F 2.0 lens
and the new HTC image processing chip
it's actually not a bad performer as you
can see the photos that it takes in
regular light are pretty average there
might not be a whole lot of dynamic
range but the photos are pretty good
even though they're not quite as sharp
as say an 8 or 13 megapixel camera in
low-light it is a stellar performer but
again we're not sure how many people
bother to take photos with their phone
in low-light but if you compare it to
something like the Nokia Lumia 920 which
actually has a massive sensor so it's a
high resolution and slightly larger
pixels you'll notice that it's it's
performing at about the same level these
are really high-end cameras in low-light
because they let so much light in per
pixel on the video side of things 4
megapixels is still significantly more
than 1920 by 1080 so there is no
sharpness problem with video
so it takes pretty decent video but
again dynamic range and color
reproduction could be a little bit
better but that's again the HTC image
processing so there is no real problem
with it being a four megapixel sensor
and that's a good sign overall it's not
the best smartphone camera out there
even though it is one of the weirdest
sounding when you say ultra pixel but
overall HTC hasn't really revolutionized
anything here they haven't used any sort
of crazy proprietary technology and
layered sensors and any chronic crazy
stuff like that they haven't invented
anything new in fact all they've done is
decrease the number of pixels and
roustabout how big the pixels now are
which is one way of looking at marketing
they took a risk that happened to be a
really good idea and dressed it up under
some fancy marketing and coated it with
a sweet name and boil up you have the
ultra pixel so there you go that's the
HTC One and the ultra pixel camera
explain hope you guys enjoyed this quick
video if you did enjoy it definitely if
you were to give a thumbs up below and I
have a couple more interesting videos at
leasing the explained video series down
below so there's a link to a playlist
below the like button and if you want to
see more videos like this definitely
subscribe but I won't take any more of
your time go ahead and watch the rest of
the explained videos thanks for watching
and I'll talk to you guys in the next
one
you